you want a man to become obsessed with you
start wearing dresses
I guarantee you they will be running back for more
they will be absolutely smitten with you
and they will be pursuing you
Not just any dress will do
don't wear anything too tight
bodycon dresses are out
skims dresses
the ones that are like super long and tight
that is the one exception
What you should wear is sundresses, tennis dress or
if you want a man running to you proposing on their knees
Wear a milk maid dress
it is the new rave and for good reason
hugs your curves, makes you look very classy and elegant
very tradwife modern day inspired
You should be looking for something floral, bright (light)
Simple colors like white will do
Men love you in white, yellows, baby blues
Nothing necessarily black (dark) unless it's for a fancy dinner
I guarantee you this will work
and honestly a little too well
so if you want a man completely obsessed with you
drooling over you
start wearing more sundresses or milk maid dresses
pull out that tennis skirt (dress)
if you don't have any of these
Go shopping and go get some!